Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is GPT-4, OpenAI’s new language model AI
that we just talked about, and today I would
love to show you that it has barely been out,
and it is already taking the world by storm.
Here are 5 incredible ways it already is
in use in the real world, in real products,
some of which you can probably try right now,
or at the very least, soon. One. In the language
learning app Duolingo, they now supercharged the
process of learning a new language with GPT-4.
We can have scripted conversations, for instance,
we can order coffee in French. That is very cool,
but that’s not the interesting part. Yet. Now,
look! GPT-4 will look at our conversation and
give us tips on how to make our French feel
a little more natural. And don’t forget,
this can be a two-way conversation, so
if we don’t quite understand what it is
trying to teach us, we can also ask
for additional examples. Loving it.
Two, Stripe, a payment processor company
puts GPT-4’s amazing information organizing
capabilities to use by letting the users
ask them a question in natural text. Now,
normally, if we have a question like
this, we would have to look through the
entire documentation and hope there is
something about it. But, from today on,
not anymore. Instead, we can now ask GPT-4 to
look through their entire documentation and
summarize the solution for us. This is going
to save a lot of time for a lot of people.
Three, my favorite, Khan Academy is also testing
a GPT-4 powered solution. If you are a student,
and have a question about, for instance,
mathematics, and the best part is, it will
behave like a real tutor and will not just give
you the solution, but it can also try to steer you
towards that solution and give you hints so you
can find it out yourself. This is going to help
millions and millions of children study all around
the world. And, it can also help with perhaps the
most dreaded question a computer science student
can ask. And of course, that is “Here is my piece
of code, but it’s not working. What’s wrong with
it?”. And it can help us with that too. That is
absolutely amazing. What a time to be alive! It
can also help teachers create a curriculum too.
Four, while we are talking about
helping us write and fix computer code,
it can look at our whole codebase, and
whenever some issue arises it can not
only tell us what is going on, but,
it will actually write that missing
subtraction function and fix the return
variable as well in one go. So cool!
And five, it can also be connected to your car,
and we can ask it about our average speed and the
current status of our battery. But that would not
be as useful. Can it do something that requires a
little more intelligence? Of course it can!
Look! It can even create a plot that shows
our speed and our battery drain for each of our
previous driving sessions. And that’s just the
first few experiments of trying to make this
incredible new AI work. And it already helps
us learn new languages, organize our knowledge,
it can become an excellent tutor when studying,
helps us fixing computer code, and also
makes our car more useful. How cool is that!
And don’t forget, GPT-4 is multimodal, so we
can not only give it text as an input, but
images too. We can ask it to explain memes, tell
us what would happen in hypothetical scenarios.
And just imagine what this will be able to
do just two more papers down the line. Maybe
a personal assistant who reads news and papers
for us, it knows our interests and summarizes
them just in the way we like it, check its sources
and points out potential flaws in the reasoning.
I would love that. But you know what? Perhaps
GPT-4 can already do that, we just need to find
a way to ask it properly. That is the incredible
world we live in today. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!